it's quite a sight seven 5:07 sitting in
front of the entrance to the BMW Museum
in Munich these rare roadsters aren't
flanking the red carpet for nothing
they've come to welcome another 507 to
Munich where a show is being held in its
honor
a total bar 5:07 expert karl-heinz
Langer says this car was quite
extraordinary and a sensation for BMW it
has an aluminium body which was quite
rare at the time and the world's first
all alloy v8 engine which providing good
driving performance he adds that the car
looks stunning it's a real showstopper
and assaulted him I know it is I'm the
guest of honor arrived earlier the red
507 had spent years collecting cobwebs
in the US and was in bad shape
but it was brought to the museum exactly
as it was even the layers of dust were
preserved
you hang off BMWs Ulrich creeps says
they've been working towards this day
for a long time they've been in contact
with the owner for years now the day has
come when they can finally show off this
unrestored vehicle to the public with
the mandate to restore it to its
original nearly new condition for mr.
Karsten to be a physician but why devote
a special show to an antique car in such
awful condition what makes this car so
unique
Klauss Kutcher says just 254 BMW 507 s
were ever built but this one's really
special it was a show car at the
Frankfurt Motor Show then race car
driver had stuck drove it in mountain
rallies then it was overhauled and sold
to Elvis Presley Kutcher says that when
Elvis returned to the US he likely took
the car with him
they assume that's what happened as the
car turned up in private ownership in
Alabama
it was then sold to Jack castor who used
it for everyday driving no stealing over
five ended so Elvis Presley drove this
507 during his stint as an American GI
in Germany now the car is receiving the
kind of star treatment once reserved for
the king of rock and roll himself even
though it's paint job is a little the
worse for wear originally white it said
that Elvis had the body painted red as
ardent female admirers kept writing
their phone numbers on it in red
lipstick today the car needs a makeover
both inside and out
it's hard to believe that the king ever
sat behind this white steering wheel
Klaus Kutcher explains that first the
vehicle will be completely dismantled
then they'll separate the aluminium
shell from the steel frame and place the
frame in an immersion bath to remove the
paint after that they'll reconstruct
what remains as Kutcher says no more
spare parts are available in the old
days they hammered out the body shell
over wooden forms but as BMWs classic
division has restored several 507 s
they've developed plastic films over
which they can hammer out the aluminium
shells
first they're celebrating the arrival of
Alice's 507 with music from the King but
soon the work will begin in earnest BMW
classic aims to finish the restoration
in two years so what will happen to the
roaster once it's been restored to its
former glory
a star like Elvis creep says it will
remain in the museum on permanent loan
in Custis BMW has persuaded mr. Castell
to let it display the car here but
castles name will appear with the
vehicle to make it clear that he's still
the owner long with its proud owner
visitors to the BMW museum can hardly
wait for the 507 to look the way it did
when the king of rock and roll sat
behind the wheel
you